justin bieber has postponed his latest
tour and revealed he has a rare
neurological disorder the singer says
part of his face is paralyzed because of
ramsay hunt syndrome bieber said it's
getting hard for him to eat he showed
his fans on instagram how it affects him
as you can see this eye is not blinking
i can't smile on this side of my face
this nostril will not move
so there's full paralysis in this side
of my face
as you can see ramsay hunt syndrome
affects nerve endings in the face and
near the ear by causing a shingles
outbreak it can lead to hearing loss the
national organization of rare disorders
says the condition affects about 5 in
one hundred thousand people doctors say
patients make a full recovery but it can
take days weeks or even months it's good
to know he's gonna fully recover so
that's good also i think it's great that
he's sharing it with us i've never heard
of ramsey hunt syndrome and the more you
see the more so much stuff can go wrong
with your body it's so genuine oh yeah
sharing it it's scary very terrifying
for anybody but particularly a performer
yeah this is his livelihood exactly hope
for a full recovery to the best i know
justin we're sending you all good things